thank you and welcome to the American
Museum of Natural History and I'm your
host for the evening and co-author of
this book talk I'm Neil deGrasse Tyson I
serve as the Frederick P Rose director
of the Hayden Planetarium a place we all
went to as a kid and it was never the
same after that come back and actually
become director we also want to welcome
c-span into this event they recording it
for book TV so c-span in the house
tonight's book is called welcome to the
universe and I love saying that I say
welcome to the universe
when you go to planetarium director of
school they teach you how to speak like
that so that's how that let me
immediately introduce my co-authors
first Michael Straus Michael Straus
right alright princess and J Richard got
the third these are my two co-authors
Chris okay
so have a seat so just a bit of
introduction I talk for 10 years at
Princeton University from 1994 through
2003 and before I transferred all of my
activities here to this museum but over
that time I taught a course on
introductory astrophysics and it got
very popular people liked it and we
moved to a bigger space and we realized
we could charge we could energize the
course even more by adding other talent
that has particular expertise that could
feed the curriculum feed the syllabus in
particular
Michael Straus is an expert on our
galaxy it's structure large-scale
structure of the universe in particular
in fact your PhD thesis was mapping the
universe that's right okay and in fact
we met in the Andes Mountains of Chile
both of us doing our PhDs back in the
1980s and we became good friends and
later colleagues Jay Richard got the
third is one of the world's experts on
Einstein's theory of relativity
so while Michael and I take you from
stars planets galaxies to the Big Bang
then we hand off to rich God and he he
you say well where do you go after that
well there can you have a deeper
understanding of the universe and this
sort of this descriptive things that it
contains and what it does and there we
learn all of the beautiful and bizarre
nuances that makes our universe what it
is pivoting on the brilliance of people
like Albert Einstein and his theories of
relativity so rich why don't you begin
oh I have to tell one just a quick
anecdote we are equal co-authors in this
book and the chapters are
have our names associated with the
lectures we had given and we speak to
the publishers whose Princeton Press and
they said well Tyson you're better known
than the other two we got to make your
name big and I said no we are equal
authors in it and then the sale feels
that no we need your name big because
you know in the publishing industry it
is your name starts out small and as you
get more known than your names like the
same size of the title then eventually
it's just your name the title is
somewhere on the cover so you're selling
your name rather than the title of the
book I said we can't add that we are
colleagues so then they handed it to the
artist the artist figure out how to do
it so my name yes if the biggest thing
on the cover what they did was they put
it on a planet that happens to just be
closer to you you see that that was so
we're all we're just on planets receding
to the background so it's like okay if
you got to do it be the artistically
clever about it and so so rich why don't
you just give us a perspective of rich
heads like show and tell here and we'll
just sit back and watch because rich got
I never know what he pulls out of his
bag even today so rich what do you have
okay well let me start off when my
granddaughter Allison was born one of
the first things I said to her was
welcome to the universe it's a phrase
you often hear from Neil when you're
born you become a citizen of the
universe and it moves you to get curious
about your surroundings and this book
will help you with that we start off
with telling you about how big the
universe is and so I brought some models
to illustrate that this this is a
hydrogen atom
it's a billion times bigger than it's
supposed to be
so this is enlarged daya factor of a
billion you know what a billion is if
you got a dollar maybe if you're lucky
you can get a hamburger if you got a
billion dollars you're a billionaire so
a billion is a big number this is a
billion times
the hydrogen atom it's a model this is
the electron in orbit around the proton
which is the central nucleus of the atom
this is a proton and the the actual size
of the proton on this scale would we be
110 thousandths of an inch so most of
the hydrogen is actually empty space
this is the most common atom in the
universe and it's the most common atom
in your body now most people might think
that they only think there's nothing
really intermediate in size between an
atom and the nucleus of the atom but
actually we found a couple of things one
of them is called muonic hydrogen this
is a hydrogen with instead of an
electron orbiting around it it has a
muon which is a heavy cousin of the
electron and it weighs 270 electoral and
so the the orbit of it is 207 times
smaller so on this scale it'd be about a
twentieth of an inch
biani it reminds me of that movie I
don't if you saw it honey I Shrunk the
Kids anybody see that well the
professor's zaps the kids with something
and they shrink down to about a quarter
of an inch in height and then they have
adventures in the backyard this is but
but it's not quite as crazy as it sounds
because if all your electrons were
replaced by muons you would shrink in
size by a factor of 207 and so you would
be tiny
unfortunately the muons decay back into
electrons by emitting a muon neutrino
and an anti-electron neutrino and an
electron and so they do this on a
timescale of two millionths of a second
and so it'd be a very short film as you
go for the short film Oscar you know
another thing that's intermediate and
decides is if you take your reign in
uranium has 92 protons and 146 neutrons
in its nucleus and if you stripped all
the electrons off of it except for one
because of the large charge it would be
92 times smaller than this and so about
about a tenth of an inch so there there
are some things we've made these
actually in the lab both of those things
so there are some things intermediate in
size between the atom and the nucleus of
the atom so this is small let's go let's
go the other way we kick him hold on you
can hold you thank you Neil can hold
thank you madam on your budget
thank you okay rich you suspended
something in the middle of it that is
well that's symbolic of the proton but
if there should be you can see it is
something that's too big because let me
go let me go the other way I'm going to
go up by a factor of billion so suppose
we shrink the earth by a factor of
billion here it is the marble have an
inch across and believe me I've got
continents painted on here so this is an
actual globe of the earth shrunk by a
factor of a billion this is a one over a
billion scale model of the earth and I
only get I got the moon in here with the
moon so small
so so here is the Mon have you super
yeah we can all see that rich and are
really good yeah it's an eighth of any
and the moon would be fifteen inches
away this is how far humans have gone in
the Apollo program this is all the
further we have gone in the universe
fifteen inches and a scale of one in a
billion
so that's that's how far the moon is
away from the earth
and does it get out here with the ticket
you take these things and how big is the
Sun well I got the circumference of the
Sun up here there's the Sun since that
big the Sun in which is that a Hot
Wheels track yeah yeah but I don't I got
to spin this so that it makes a sphere
this is this is this is how big the Sun
is it's it's 55 inch beach ball and it's
about 500 feet away that's that's how
big the Sun is that's if earth is that
marble but if we're a marble you've
heard of there is a blue marble well
there it is it's a marble one in a
billion
this is going to sign this is the Sun
how big the Sun is and it's it's 500
feet away that's it for the Sun and now
the question would be well how far away
is the next nearest star the Sun is a
star but there's a next nearest star
it's called Proxima Centauri and here it
is there it is whoops
so here's Proxima Centauri it's a red
dwarf star so it's smaller than the Sun
this is 4.3 light years away roughly it
is that means it will take light about
four years to get to to us from it which
is to be clear that's the actual size of
Proxima Centauri relative to the Sun
usually I like to drop it back on the
stage yes Oliveira there too so this is
a scale of one in a billion it's smaller
than the Sun and this would be on the
model this would be 24,000 miles away so
we could go all the way around the
circumference of the earth I'll hand it
to you don't you want me to stencil it
yeah well we'll get to that yeah you can
go over there stand over there
so he's going to hold no oh here this
was handed yep so he's holding Proxima
Centauri here okay it's 25,000 miles
away from us on this model scale and
then we recently discovered a planet
there's a planet going around this star
it's a little bit bigger than the earth
and so it's it's about 24 feet away from
its star here this is a plan a little
bit bigger than the earth and it's close
enough to the star there
it's tidally locked so it only always
keeps should always keep one face toward
the star and the other face away as it
orbits around so one side is going to be
too hot no side is going to be too cold
so not too likely to be habitable but
this is the nearest planet to us that we
have that we have found and that's how
far away it is okay wait so rich I well
keeping the same scale you've got the
moon a blue marble
you've got no sorry so every blue marble
level the moon 15 inches away from that
little blue marble and then the Sun that
size and then Proxima Centuri
24
and miles away that's a lot of empty
space okay so and it's the nearest star
so the farthest we've been is the moon
yeah what hope do you have for the
future of space travel well you just
have to get that much better okay you
have to stand away I just and more mine
okay okay so so okay let's go let's go
up by another factor a billion and I'll
show you a model in a scale of one not
one over a billion which is what we just
saw but one over a billion billion this
is a billion times smaller also so
here's here's the Sun there's the Sun
there's the Sun and there is alpha this
is Alpha Centauri
this is another solar type star it's
part of a triple star system that
includes Proxima Centauri and beta
Centauri and Alpha Centauri
so it's a triple star system but the
brightest one is a solar type star and
it's again about 4.3 light years away
and here on the same scale as Sirius
it's a blue star you've seen that in the
northern sky it's the brightest star in
the sky this is this is it's about nine
light years away so these are the
nearest some near stars to us and we're
living in the Milky Way
it has 300 billion stars in it and it
would be about a tenth of a mile across
on this scale a big disk of stars and
they're about this distance apart so if
you went through this model at a scale
of 1 over a billion billion it would be
like going through a snowstorm of stars
and the next nearest big galaxy to us is
Andromeda which would be another galaxy
about 20 miles away on this scale so so
rich if you got another 299 billion two
hundred ninety nine million two hundred
ninety nine thousand two hundred ninety
seven lights I'd be ready you could
reconstruct our Delhi to work on this
model bit more yes so so now we got that
scale but let's go let's go up another
factor of a billion so now let's look at
a model it's in a scale of one over a
billion billion billion two billion
times smaller than this and then you can
see the entire visible universe here
we're at the center of this this is the
cosmic microwave background radiation
it's as far as we can see the the
universe is 13.8 billion years old since
the Big Bang and the radiation from this
Cosmic Microwave Background which is
left over from the Big Bang has been
coming toward us for 13.8 billion years
so the radius of this and what we call
look-back time distance is 13.8 billion
light years that's the radius of this
sphere and so where we look out in space
we're looking back in time because of
the finite speed of light and so this is
as far as we can see and inside this
sphere there are a hundred and thirty
billion other galaxies each one of them
with several hundred billion stars in
them and so this is the Cosmic Microwave
Background that we can that we can see
now we can't see anything beyond this
but like from those regions simply
hasn't had time to get to us rich you
just put yourself in a rather privileged
vantage point to even show that yes okay
what is this this is what we see it's
just like if you stand on top of the
Empire State Building you're going to
see a circle out to the horizon that's
as far as you can see it's a bit
centered on the Empire State Building if
you go to the the Willis Tower in
Chicago you're going to see part of
Chicago it's going to be centered on you
so the part you can see is always
centered on you that doesn't mean you're
special
everybody everybody sees that okay so
everywhere you go there you are
so this is this is we see this and we
have reason to believe though that the
universe is much bigger than this
because the fluctuations in this are
only one part in a hundred thousand we
believe the universe is at least a
hundred thousand times as large as this
and probably much larger the the best
theory for explaining in detail the
pattern of fluctuations that we see in
this Cosmic Microwave Background sphere
which is this is based on the
observations from the W map satellite is
the theory of inflation which Alan Guth
put forward in 1981 and in that theory
that explains how the Big Bang got
started and it what it says is that you
could have started the universe with a
very tiny region ten to the minus twenty
seven centimeters across of high energy
vacuum State what is that okay well
we're used to thinking of the vacuum as
being empty I mean if everybody left the
auditorium here and if we took away all
the air we took away all the photons a
completely empty space you think that
would be zero energy density but in fact
because the various fields going through
the universe like the Higgs field that
we've discovered recently the Higgs
particle for the universe can have a
vacuum energy a nonzero vacuum energy
and so if it has a nonzero vacuum energy
because we we would like the vacuum not
to have any privileged standard of rest
so if rocket ships going through this
vacuum at different speeds are all going
to measure the same vacuum energy by the
logic of special relativity it must be
that this vacuum energy is associated
with a negative vacuum pressure that
operates in three directions
front back left right and and up and
down and Accord this is uniform pressure
so it exerts no hydrodynamic effects so
in the room here we've got a air
pressure of 15 pounds per square inch
but you don't notice it
it's uniform if they have difference in
pressure to make the wind blow and knock
you over so this is a uniform pressure
as no hydrodynamic effect but it has a
gravitational effect according to
general relativity because pressure
gravitates as well as energy in general
relativity Einstein's theory of curved
space-time and so that means that it has
a repulsive effect because it's a
negative pressure and it operates in
three directions so it's three times
more potent than the attraction caused
by the energy density so this causes a
gravitational repulsion and it starts
the universe expanding and it expands
faster and faster in an accelerated rate
so it keeps doubling and doubling in
size once every maybe ten to the minus
thirty eight seconds so in the first ten
to the minus 35 seconds of the universe
existence it could it could double in
size a thousand times and that's ten to
the 300 in size so it can become truly
enormous this explains why the universe
is so enormous also explains why so
uniform as it is and in detail it can
explain the pattern of fluctuations that
we see we so the theory of inflation is
very effective at explaining this one of
the problems it had though is that what
you want to have happen is you want this
high energy vacuum in the early universe
to decay into normal particles to make
the hot Big Bang that we see we wanted
to dump its energy into the form of
normal elementary particles and so the
problem with this was that it's like
you're trying to boil water on the stove
and have the water represents this
inflating sea of vacuum energy which is
inflating very very fast and you want it
to turn all into steam and ordinary
particles but what happens is if you
ever blow the water on the stove what
happens is that it forms bubbles and so
we expected to get bubbles of particles
forming in this and that didn't look
uniform so I was one of the
people myself and Andrei Linde a and
Albrecht and Steinhardt who proposed in
1982 that what happened was that we were
living in one of the bubbles these were
individual bubble universes that were
expanding and from inside the bubble it
looks perfectly in a form to you and the
other bubbles are so far away that the
light hasn't gotten to you from them yet
so this solved that problem of non
uniformity with inflation and this was
called a new inflation and that theory
predicts in a rather general way that
once you get inflation started it's
really impossible to stop and it's just
going to keep making more and more
bubbles universes forever if it
continues to double and double in size
and eventually get an infinite number of
bubble universes and these can have
different laws of physics in them and so
you get a multiverse we actually think
we live in a multiverse and so this is
all vast compared with the tiny region
that we can see and one of the reasons
we believe that these other universes
out there exist is that the theory of
inflation predicts it and the theory of
inflation as we show in the book
beautifully explains the pattern of
fluctuations that we actually observe in
the Cosmic Microwave Background and
another reason we believe in inflation
is that we're actually observing
inflation starting again in the universe
in a rather low-key fashion we're seeing
the universe today an accelerated
expansion two groups found this in 1997
they won the Nobel Prize for this and
the universe is going to be doubling in
size once every 12 point 2 billion years
and today which has a very low vacuum
energy of seven times 10 to the minus 30
grams per cubic centimeter so so we've
seen a low-grade form of inflation even
occurring today so this is another
reason we believe in inflation so I've
talked about sizes in the universe
and one of the reasons that people think
that Pluto got demoted was because of
its miniscule size and so I'd like Neil
to tell us about that story because he
was a big participant rich you took us
from the hydrogen atom to multiverses
and then you dumped Pluto in my lap yeah
just to be clear elegant I think in the
visual above my head we have what are
called the terrestrial planets these are
the planets that have surfaces you can
walk on Mercury Venus Earth and Mars the
moon is also shown there which looks
quite small but something to know about
our moon is that it's one of the largest
moons in the solar system
so even most of the moons of Jupiter and
Saturn are dwarfed by the size of our
moon we have an uncommonly large moon
relative to us in spite of how small
that looks so the point I want to make
here is Pluto people equate we have
history here with Pluto in this
institution in back in 2000 when we
opened the Rose Center for Earth and
space we were kind of the first
out-of-the-box to reassociate Pluto's
identity from the company of planets to
the eye see the dirty ice balls in the
outer solar system the Kuiper belt and
so we were sort of ranked over the coals
by the press saying and especially
little kids say you know third angry
pissed-off third graders saying how
could you pause just because it's small
how could you do that and they're
thinking that size was an issue and in
fact it it had much less to do with size
than you might imagine if we just go to
the next slide here what do we have so
now we have the gas giants Jupiter
Saturn Uranus and Neptune relative to a
segment of
the Sun and then you get to see how
small earth is relative to the rest of
the action there and because earth is
included in this for scale so here's a
point I'll make and I don't get to make
this often enough that Jupiter is more
bigger compared to earth than Earth is
compared to Pluto okay I don't know how
else to conjugate those verbs in that
sentence but does it make sense do but
so in other words if we're on earth
saying we're big enough to be a planet
but Pluto isn't then imagine what
Jovians could be saying they're saying
the solar system has only four planets
Jupiter Saturn Uranus and Neptune and
everything else is just a debris so so
[Laughter]
I'm certain all life-forms of Jupiter
are thinking exactly that way so so you
can't invoke size exclusively to to diss
Pluto in this regard but allow me to
tell you that our moon as small as it
was compared to earth has five times the
mass of Pluto yes some people over here
yes Oh Pluto lovers never we're told
that were you right yeah so it's welcome
to the company of informed people all
right regarding Pluto so but we knew
this so so at Pluto had other issues and
so after some thinking about this Pluto
got demoted to a dwarf planet status on
several grounds one of which is that it
orbits the Sun in a region of the solar
system where there's plenty of other
stuff
orbiting there which in total dwarfs the
mass of Pluto itself so Pluto does not
how would we call it own its orbital
place in the solar system
it's shared with countless thousands of
other eye
see bodies that rival Pluto in in size
and composition so what we really
discovered was that Pluto really never
was the planet we wanted it to be in
fact it just went 60 years before we had
discovered it's icy brethren orbiting
beyond Neptune and this I see brethren
we've named for an astronomer at
mid-century named Gerard Kuiper who
hypothesized that there could be this
repository of excess debris that didn't
participate in the formation of the rest
of the planets so Pluto is a very
healthy Kuiper belt object but a really
lame planet right so just to make that
clear now when we look for other planets
which has been quite the the past time
these last several years by the way I'm
curious if there's anyone in the
audience that is 21 and younger raise
your hand for you're 21 yo there's
several of you means you're born in 1995
or later
well 1995 was the year we discovered our
firt we our community of astrophysicists
discovered the first exoplanet first
planet in orbit around another star
so I want to denied all of you born
since 1995 generation exoplanet okay
because you've only known life in a
world where we've known of worlds beyond
the backyard of the solar system and so
what a privilege that is so so in our
book we calculate how you might go about
finding exoplanets that would be a
particular interest to us and what is it
you'd be after not necessarily rings
although rings are quite beautiful
really at the end of the day you're
after
whether it can harbor life life as we
know it perhaps life of any kind and so
so there are ways to approach that
problem and one of them is called the
the Drake Equation named after Frank
Drake
woman whatever ready to go there oh yeah
sure what has put him up that's an image
of Frank Drake up in the corner uh I
think he's like much older than that now
that is he still alive yes yeah good
good okay good to know
no okay he's a hundred and thirty last
night round so Frank Drake who's in was
early in this exercise of asking what is
the likelihood of us communicating with
alien intelligence that could lurk in a
planet out there in the galaxy and so he
came up with a clever way to attack the
problem so you come up with an equation
that and that's him writing his equation
sitting under his pen in that photo what
I've done in this slide has made a sort
of a simplified version of it to get the
idea across but there's several other
terms in the equation that he's written
but let me start with his simplified
version so we get the idea what we want
to calculate is the number of
civilizations that could be out there
let's just start with that so this would
be life that has achieved intelligence
and has created organized societies
civilizations so that's that curly n the
number of civilizations how would you go
about doing that well used to be what
you want to do is split the problem into
multiple bits and each bit each part of
that problem could be entire science
projects to try to address and that way
what we say in our field is you unpack
the problem separating the variables
otherwise it's this Maelstrom and you
don't know if you're coming to going or
what's influencing what so we start out
with how many total stars there are that
you could be searching and that's n
stars so in this case there would be the
number of stars in the galaxy the Milky
Way galaxy and that's coming in it
lately at about 300 billion over the
years you might have seen a hundred
billion Carl Sagan that's at four
hundred billion this is just just those
all those numbers are the same to us
what's a few hundred billion between
friends really rigid no I say that not
facetiously there are galaxies that have
a trillion stars and galaxies that have
only
a few hundred million so with your if
you're in a few factors a hundred
billion that's the same number to us
given the range of sizes of things that
are out there so start with the number
of stars and what you want to do is ask
what fraction of those stars have
planets because you're going to look for
life where there's a planet presumably
you don't expect life thriving in stars
okay
that's hazardous to molecules okay and
life so so what fraction of those have
planets and so that would be its own
Astrophysical exercise you'd ask you you
created a telescope mounted on a
satellite which we've done it's called
the Kepler satellite and it measured a
piece of the sky and it looked for what
fraction of the stars and that piece of
sky have planted okay you can do that
now it turns out not all planets are
good for life some might be too close to
the host star be too hot too far away
too cold well too hot or too cold for
what well life as we know it requires
liquid water so you would want the zone
around a star to be just right the
Goldilocks zone and if you're looking
for planets you kind of want to plant it
in that zone if you're looking for life
as we know it so while we didn't specify
that as its own term fraction of planets
in the Goldilocks zone you can imagine
that as its own term separately measured
from just the fraction of stars the
planets around them okay so now we've
got some fraction of stop fraction of
the total stars left that have planets
that have planets that can sustain life
in the Goldilocks so now you want to ask
how many do sustain life is it half of
those is it 1/10 we don't really know
when so not all these terms have equal
equal confidence in the numbers we
insert
okay but you keep going if it does have
life what fraction of those planets that
are it of the stars that have planets in
the Goldilocks zone that have life what
fraction of those have intelligent life
so here we are hacking away at that
number 300 billion is it one in a
hundred times one and a thousand times
whatever these fractions are you're
hacking away at the number but it's a
big number so there's a lot of wiggle
room to give you something left over at
the end so you keep going by the way
these are civilizations you would talk
to in some way well how would you do
that
if they don't have technology to send
signals through space think about it
most of human cultural history we had
what we would call intelligence but
there's no way they could have had a
conversation with an alien they didn't
have technology they didn't have radio
waves they didn't know anything about it
so just because you're intelligent
doesn't mean you are Katyn that you're a
candidate to communicate with as this is
set up we're just counting civilizations
but you add up all of those terms and
ask how long have we been able to use
radio waves maybe a hundred years out of
the thousands of years of cultural human
history hundred years so if you threw a
dart at the timeline of civilization
what fraction you know do that blindly
what fraction of the time does that dart
hit us with our capability to
communicate with aliens it's a tiny
fraction before any measure of things so
to come upon a planet randomly in its
it's life what are you likely to find
that's the kind of questions that are
addressed in this equation and when you
put in the very latest numbers you put
in all the numbers and all the terms
what we come up with is rich what's the
number of civilizations in the galaxy
what was it oh no a red planet's 1.8
billion habitable planets so these are
planets in
the habitable zone in the habitable zone
one we like billion earth likes I gotta
say that right 1.8 billion billion and
just go to planetarium director school
today okay so now and maybe as many as
is what the rigid so that would be like
right heat those are planets capable of
hosting life as we know it couple the
first couple of terms here yeah and the
other one could be could be as big as
may be smaller than but could be as big
as a hundred that are communicating with
radio waves now I 100 in the galaxy yeah
so that's hopeful that's all the whole
and there are other galaxy's don't
forget about that so if we go to the
next slide rich you've got so here's an
image taken from the southern hemisphere
of the Milky Way galaxy so let me
explain to New Yorkers this is what the
sky looks like if you remove the
buildings in the light and the pollution
and I think you know one day I want to
write a novel that implicates the
amateur astronomy a community for all
the major blackouts that New York has
experienced right you parked the
curtains and there they were unplugging
in New York so forcing you to come out
and look up and notice like Venus and
the moon and things so it's stunning and
just to embrace the sheer scale of what
it to search for the life in the
universe but to recognize that there's a
hundred and eighty billion planets in
habitable zones one point one point
eight billion
scattered across the galaxy that's the
plane of the Milky Way galaxy we are in
the galaxy within it and that is the
plane all the other stars you see above
and below are also part of our galaxy
they're just really close to us they're
like a blueberry embedded in a pancake
you can look out above and below and
escape the dough of the pancake but if
you look within the plane of the pancake
it's just pancake all the way around so
when you look in the plane of the galaxy
we have galaxies all the way around us
this completely wraps the sky and I want
to note for you
rich God mentioned that our Neil is
nearest large galaxy is the andromeda
galaxy named so because it appears among
the stars identified with the
constellation Andromeda but of course
it's much farther away the stars in the
constellation are just part of our own
galaxy looking through a screen door out
to the rest of the universe this image
in the southern hemisphere has two fuzzy
cloudy things off to the bottom there
and whatever just point in the map oh
yeah people people don't yeah I got I
got money people know well appointment
okay so was that not clear weird weather
I said to fuzzy things down man
alright so they look like clouds and
while native inhabitants of the southern
hemisphere surely knew all about this
we in the West first learned of it from
the journals of Magellan who upon
circumnavigating the globe went through
the southern hemisphere saw these clouds
notice they never left but he still
called them clouds because that's what
they look like and to lit to this day in
our field we refer to them as the
Magellanic Clouds we know that now to be
dwarf galaxies in orbit gravitationally
bound to the Milky Way and so they're
nearby and by the way it's not all roses
for small galaxies in orbit around big
galaxies we have a record of small
galaxies that once orbited us that have
been completely cannibalized and we see
just the remnants of streams of stars
fully absorbed into our own stellar
system so dwarf galaxies have very
limited lives when they have to hang out
around these big systems so I mention
that because we will make reference
again to the Large Magellanic Cloud the
larger of these two fuzzy things in the
sky but like I think that's my last oh
yeah so just just to be clear I don't
know if we could dim the lights just
briefly and then bring them back up and
we'll see what seems c-span can handle
it yeah there we go uh what you have
here is one of the most famous images
ever taken and it's of course by the
Hubble Space Telescope and it's called
the Hubble Ultra Deep Field and by deep
we mean how far into the universe does
that picture reach and of course it's a
NASA photo and I want notice there's a
reddish object with spikes that's a star
sitting on our nose in our own galaxy
and that might be the only star in that
photo yes it is every other smudge every
other speck of light is beyond the stars
of our Milky Way and they represent
entire other galaxies each containing
hundreds of billions of stars so when we
talk about the probability of life we
generally contain it within just our own
Milky Way but if you want to multiply up
by the scale of the universe and all the
galaxies contained within it you've got
you would you would have you would be
inexcusably egocentric to suggest that
we are the only life in this universe
the Hubble Deep Field and by the way
this is a tuck this area on the sky is a
tiny fraction of the area of the full
moon so you take this and multiply it
out by all the points to all the these
tiles that you can fill up the sky with
and you get us that's how you recover
these numbers such as the universe
contains
hundred thirty what is the latest
estimate one hundred and thirty billion
galaxies we can bring the lights back up
there so let me now hand off to Mike
what can you tell us Mike hit
all right easy I gotta move you gotta
move okay sorry okay so we're going to
go back to the Milky Way this is a view
of the Milky Way from the surfer Lolo
interm inter-american Observatory which
is in fact where Neil and I met each
other just almost 30 years ago no it was
a couple of years ago just a couple
feels like I said we work out our
respective species Neil I think you were
using the four meter telescope there
briefly but I was primarily on the point
9 meter on the point not yeah okay which
is just off the screen using the 1.5
meter and you can see the Milky Way
rising dramatically and coming over our
head one of the frustrations even if you
get away from New York City's bright
lights one of the frustrations are being
in the northern hemisphere is that the
Brandes parts of the Milky Way are
really not visible to us you have to
travel to the southern hemisphere to see
this dramatic part of the Milky Way
we're actually looking straight to the
galaxy's center and we'll have much more
to see to say about that there's I just
add something here roughly because now
you because this is this is your memory
lane now so this is at the summit of a
mountain in the Andes yes and
occasionally you get weather that is
below you
okay cloud total cloud cover below you
on the top of this mountain and if
there's any moonlight at all and you
just look out over the edge of the
mountain it is like you are you are se
you are somewhere on unreal
you are otherworldly because the you're
an island in the middle of clouds and
there is no earth it's just you the
telescope in the cosmos so with that I
mean and let me say what I gotta say so
so so I may be the last we may be the
last generation of astrophysicist who
actually went to mountaintops to obtain
our data in the pilgrimage that this
represents a plane to to Santiago and
then transport to la serena and then
practically mule train up
the mountain and then you invert and
live nocturnally because the night
becomes your day as the day becomes your
night and within a few years of that we
now have what's called service observing
we just send your coordinates and give
the specs and then they the day point
the telescope is all automated they send
you back the data and you never left
your desk you know in your office so
it's way more efficient but I think it's
absent some of the romance which I was
minted oh sorry ok I'll shut up go so
what we do is we set up a long exposure
with our telescopes and the telescopes
even 30 years ago were fairly automated
so they took care of themselves when we
come outside and enjoy the spectacular
view and indeed isma'il has just
described it is spectacular it is
wonderful and so we don't there are
several telescopes at the observatory as
you can see and so we'd also often bump
into each other there on the mountaintop
enjoying the view and I and I in
addition to Neil and myself working on
our respective PhD thesis I met the
woman who would later become my wife
Sofia and she was on actually also on
the point 9 meter also just about 30
years ago so I will I will I just wanted
to mention that here so let's let's talk
a little bit about what the nature of
the Milky Way is we've seen that it's
300 billion stars and so one of the
questions we want to ask ourselves is
really what is a star we've Neil has
already told you that they're
tremendously hot we've heard from rich
just how enormous they are a star is a
ball of gas held together by its own
gravity but held up by its internal
pressure and giving off as we see a
great deal of heat and light which is in
in the case of the Sun what keeps what
keeps us alive and so one of the great
triumphs of astrophysics in the 20th
century is learning what the stars are
actually made of and one of the great
discoveries indeed is that stars are
made up of almost entirely of hydrogen
and helium what we have here are the
elements of the periodic table indicated
the size of each box is proportional to
the fraction of the mass of atoms that
you find in stars hydrogen in helium
dominate the elements of the universe by
far and everything else represents just
a trace the carbon and oxygen the makeup
of our bodies and neon and magnesium and
on and on are just a small fraction a
tiny fraction of the atoms in the
universe and so one of the fundamental
questions that we next want to ask is
why is that the case how is it that the
that the universe has come this way and
we describe this in the book the
hydrogen and helium in the universe came
to us from the Big Bang itself the early
universe was tremendously hot much
hotter than then the surface of stars
temperatures that range up to billions
of degrees we like that billions of
course nucleus far better than I can
billions I'll practice again point to me
when you need it was so hot that stars
could not exist planets could not exist
molecules could not exist even atoms
could not exist it was so hot that the
only things that could exist for the
present discussion are protons and
neutrons protons being the cores the
nuclei of hydrogen atoms and as the
universe expanded and cooled even in the
first few minutes some of those protons
and neutrons came together to make
helium and indeed one of the great
triumphs of our understanding of the
early universe in the expanding universe
is that we can predict the amount of
helium that was produced at a helium
nuclei that were produced in that early
phases of the Big Bang and it matches
wonderfully with the experimental values
now measured by by measuring the spectra
of stars so and that's it basically the
earth the early universe gives us the
hydrogen helium and it was first thought
that we that we would be able to explain
the rest of the periodic table all the
other elements of the universe from the
from the Big Bang itself it turns out
not to work and so we need another
explanation to see how those heavier
elements are made and the answer is
going back to the stars if you go back
to the Sun and ask is that going to work
as a movie with scoops there we are
if we go back to the Sun and ask the
question what is happening in the center
the fuel source that's that causing the
Sun to shine the answer is it in the
very core of the Sun where's fifteen
million not billion million degrees
Kelvin million tremendous tremendous
relief i pressure under those conditions
the hydrogen nuclei the protons confused
together a process called nuclear fusion
to make helium nuclei and release some
energy in the process we describe that
process in the book hydrogen is being
formed into helium and that is a process
that's going on in the Sun right now the
story gets much more interesting for
more massive stars our own Sun will be
able to burn hydrogen into helium and
then later turn helium into carbon and
oxygen which again our primary elements
that make up our own bodies but if you
want to get the rest of the periodic
table you need more massive stars a star
may be eight times as massive massive as
the Sun as it continues to grow and use
up first the hydrogen in its core
then the helium then the carbon and
oxygen can burn ever heavier elements
and start creating elements of ever
larger masses working one your way up
the periodic table now it turns out that
iron which is element number 26 in their
periodic table is the end of the story
you cannot combine iron with anything
iron nuclei with anything and get energy
out it requires energy to combine iron
with anything to make a heavier element
and so what so when the star gets to the
point where the core is made purely of
iron then the interior energy source is
gone the source the star is being held
together by gravity I told you that the
furnace in the center the is giving you
a pressure that's holding the star up
you turn that furnace off the star has
no no choice but to collapse and it
collapses catastrophic ly and in doing
so explodes the outer parts of the star
that have not yet reacted undergo
nuclear reactions at a tremendous rate
and the star explodes in what is called
a supernova
so let's go ahead whoops we know they
supernova exists because we can see the
leftovers this is a particularly famous
supernova called the Crab Nebula
observed by the Hubble Space Telescope
what we're seeing is the Neil it's your
favorite where the smithereens of the
star broken into this this is known to
be a star that exploded in 1054 ad how
do we know that it's 1054 ad because the
Chinese left records they actually
thought explode there was what they
called a guest star that appeared in the
sky it was broad enough to be seen for
several weeks even during the day we
look at the position in the sky that the
Chinese said the star lay and we find
this this dramatic residue of that
exploded star and the gas that we see
here has all those heavier elements
built into it just to be clear this is a
guts of the star this is not guys are it
so these are the blown apart guts that's
that is right it's really nasty okay but
but also astrophysicist today celebrate
that explosion every year because the
chinese observed it on July 4th and so
we have fireworks and astrophysics
community celebrating the Crab Nebula
just FYI it turns out that in that
explosion it didn't it didn't destroy
the star completely right in the middle
of here I don't know maybe that spot
right there I believe it is is something
called a neutron star incredibly dense
Retta center part of the star maybe
about the mass of the Sun made up of
essentially pure neutrons tremendously
dense again the mass of the Sun maybe
only 10 kilometers a second across one
symbol full of neutron star stuff I
think we said weighs about as much as a
hundred million elephants if you can get
your thought get your mind around such
an incredibly incredible thing so so
remember I said that the iron that the
star can make only iron and then the
process star stops and then the then the
star explodes as a supernova there is so
much energy in that explosion that
your elements could be made and if you
and so there are two different
explosions that heavier elements could
be made and if you and so there are two
different stories that we now are trying
to understand as possible ways to make
the heavier elements beyond iron in the
periodic table one is that they are
formed in the explosion of supernovae
the other is that you imagine that you
have two of these neutron stars and they
collide together which we one can happen
under very special circumstances that's
another way to give you that energy to
get those incredibly heavy elements so
think about it the gold in my wedding
ring here is formed in the center of an
explosion just like the one we see and
in fact most of the atoms in our body
that carbon and the oxygen and all the
other elements other than the hydrogen
and helium were forged in the interiors
of stars on one sort or another so it's
a it's an awesome thought to think about
so this there that was a supernova in
1054 ad in 1987 which again is just
about 30 years ago February 23rd it was
observed in the Large Magellanic Cloud
which Neil pointed out to you in the
picture of the night sky a supernova
went off this particular star right
there's got an arrow exploded boom and
for weeks afterwards astronomers meeting
each other in the hall would just say
boom and be incredibly excited it was a
very fun time to be an astronomer I was
lucky enough in May of that of that year
I think this may be the time that I then
I met Neil to travel to the southern
hemisphere the Large Magellanic Cloud is
not visible to us here in the northern
hemisphere you have to travel to the
south and to actually see that that the
supernova with my naked eye from 150,000
light-years away that light of a single
star was visible Michael the guy who
discovered this yes was in the telescope
dome yes when it happened and he just
didn't believe it and he and so he just
went outside and will talk like there it
was so there's a new star there really
very dramatic it's certainly one of the
most dramatic
astronomical discoveries of our time is
the closest supernova that had exploded
to us in 400 years since the invention
of the telescope but plus the very
literal translation of supernovae means
new you know super renew / new but in
fact it's a dying star which we would
later learn yeah yeah
so it's a new star to you if you don't
know astrophysics that's what that
happens yeah so I want to go back to the
Milky Way and talk a little bit about
this I don't Neil did not mention that
his own specialty in his thesis was
studying the stars in the very center of
the Milky Way this is a movie from the
European Southern Observatory zooming
into the Milky Way and we're going to go
to the very center and the very center
of the Milky Way is a special place
partly because Neil studied that stars
there but but at the very center we find
something which is truly dramatic
there's a black hole sitting in the very
center of the book of the Milky Way now
a black hole is black it is as you
probably know something so dense that
nothing can escape from it not even
light so how can we infer its existence
if it is almost by definition invisible
well it has no light for us to see but
we do see we do see its gravitational
influence on the stars around us so this
is a diagram of a indicating
observations carried out with the Keck
telescope by Andre Agassi and her
colleagues at UCLA what she has done is
mapped the orbits of individual stars in
the very center of the Milky Way where
we have zoomed in to that very center
and what you see at the stars all seem
to be orbiting around a single point
right in the middle they're marked with
the star to guide the eye no light is
seen at that spot but you can infer from
those orbits just how much mass must be
associated and and also get some limit
on how large the object is so we see
something that's invisible very very
tiny and incredibly massive four million
times the mass of our own Sun and what
and what indeed is that object we infer
that it is a black hole
invisible incredibly massive and
incredibly dense and indeed
the one of the great discoveries of the
last 15 or 20 years is the realization
not only does the Milky Way have a
supermassive black hole in the center
but in fact all galaxies all large
galaxies at least seem to have a similar
supermassive black hole with masses up
to a billion Neil please do you thank
you a few billion times the mass of the
Sun so one of the things that I that has
been part of my scientific Brennan
brother is studying uh studying those
very massive black holes I said that a
black hole is so dense that we can't we
can't see it the no light can possibly
escape but there is a there's a way to
another way to infer the presence of a
black hole
imagine that there is gas flowing into
that black hole as it falls in it heats
up tremendously and glows brightly so
brightly that that that that glowing
brightness which we call a quasar can be
seen most of the way to the edge of the
observable universe we already know that
the universe is 13.8 billion light years
away and therefore that represents a
limit the visible universe that part of
the universe that has had time for the
light to reach us and so what we see
here you see the arrow points a good
thing we have that arrow there points to
this to this quasar that is seen about
13 billion light years away the
so-called light travel time distance
seen at a time when the universe was a
mere nine hundred million years after
the Big Bang we're looking back to a
time when the universe was only a tiny
fraction of the present age and studying
such objects gives us important clues to
understand how the universe has evolved
and what was going on
so Michael Clyde Tombaugh when he
discovered Pluto yes gave a series of
lectures about it and there's this
little dot on the screen with an arrow
no death an hour and they said how did
you how did you know that was Pluto and
he said there was an arrow point really
cute very similar very much a needle in
a haystack
Torian do so black holes are interesting
one of the really dramatic discoveries
over the last year and we were able to
get it in to the book just in time was
the discovery and perhaps the most
direct evidence yet in really proof that
black holes as Einstein's general theory
of relativity describes them actually
exist
imagine two black holes swirling around
each other just as you see there
Einstein's theory of general relativity
predicts that those two black holes as
they go around each other warp space and
time and send ripples of distorted space
and time like ripples and when you throw
a stone into a pond send that out into
into space traveling at the speed of
light that carries energy that lost
energy causes the two black holes to get
closer and closer together and
eventually to merge this has been
predicted for a very long time and a an
observatory called LIGO the laser
interferometer gravitational-wave
Observatory I think I said that right
was built to measure the incredibly
subtle distortions in the in the fabric
of space and time as this wave passes by
it measures it basically consists of an
extremely long ruler about four
kilometers long and measured a change in
that that four kilometer long length by
about a thousandth the width of a single
proton and what they inferred was a pair
of black holes 129 times the mass of the
Sun the other 36 times the mass of the
Sun merging together as shown in this
movie to make a single black hole with a
mass of 62 times the mass of the Sun and
some of you who may be following the
numbers will say wait a minute that
doesn't make sense
29 plus 36 does not equal 62 something
seems to be missing that missing piece
is is the energy lost in the form of
gravitational waves three times the mass
of the Sun times C squared remember
Einstein tells you e equals MC squared
three times the mass of Sun times C
squared was lost in the form of energy
in the collision of those
of those two black holes and we detected
the faint trace of that with the lego
satellite not satellite excuse me the
LIGO Observatory proving directly and
demonstrating is some quantitative
detail that that black holes actually
exist in fact that conversion of that
those multiple solar masses equivalent
into energy in that moment made this the
most energetic saying in the universe by
a factor of a thousand yes for for just
a fraction of netiquette that's correct
so and incredibly dramatic so we are now
at an important threshold in in our
study of astronomy an entire new window
will wait for us to not just see what's
happening in the universe but listen
these these gravitational waves at truly
exciting development and I will this is
just a quick diagram showing showing the
actual measurements and some comparison
with what was observed let me just skip
that and go on to talk about sort of the
future here one of the wonderful things
about the universe as you know the
universe is a very big place we heard
this in some detail from rich and
there's a lot of exploration to do we
are still very much in the exploration
mode in the sense that by making maps we
can learn about what we can learn
fundamental new things about the
universe by just seeing what's out there
we can we can see what's happening so
this is a an artist conception of
something called the large synoptic
survey telescope which is being built in
Chile at a mountaintop just one
literally one Mountain over from Sirte
low of the observatory that we had seen
before and an artist's conception of of
what the stars and galaxies that will
see this telescope is being built now
starting in 2022 it will start a 10-year
survey making a map of the sky not just
one map but it will make multiple maps
repeatedly asking the question how does
the universe
change can we see new exploding stars
can we see new new asteroids or phenom
phenomenal have not been had the
imagination yet to discover now I
mentioned that 30 years ago
Sophia and I met each other at Sur -
Lolo we were very lucky to be able to
travel to Chile last year for the for
what was just about our 25th anniversary
and it was also the ceremony marking the
start of the construction of the
observatory so here is the two of us
standing on the mountain top the
mountain top where we met is just one
mountain over just over there and again
starting the construction and starting
in 2022 the scientific function we
allowed to stand that close to that
emergency cone just wondering there we
are so with that I think we're going to
change change mode Karen would turn it
back to rich yeah in the book we have a
map of the universe it stretches over
several pages and from left to right
this is a panorama looking out from the
earth's equator and then it's vertically
shows distance away from the earth it's
a map that preserves shapes and it is
like the Mercator map does on the earth
and it is logarithmic so each constant
step outwards here is another factor of
10 further away from the earth and so we
have let me point out here you can point
with this at the movie well not yet
there's the earth surface and there's
the there's your sadness fellow there
and there's the satellites going around
what you say about the other service
people just and it's made very clear
here that our surface in a way is the
shoreline of a cosmic ocean that lay
before us and this is a an idea that's
been with us for some time since the era
of Sagan there's the moon yeah this is
this is that satellite that measured the
Cosmic Microwave Background and now
we're at Soho this is the solar or
Heliospheric Observatory that made the
measurement so the Sun that we saw now
we're getting into the realm of the
planets and from which we heard about it
we don't leave out the near-earth
objects as all the things that could
render us extinct I mean
yeah and so of course what one of the
things that LSST project will do is try
to map those and find out if any of
those are going to hit us in the head
Pluto is coming out there I'm sure Neil
you have something to say about that
ah so this is the farthest well there's
Pluto okay fine and the Kuiper belt a
Halley's Comet we've got a Voyager 1 and
2 and the heliopause is the transition
between the Sun and its influence on its
environment in the galaxy and the rest
of the galaxy
so what's Julius Caesar's calling what
the hell was a close one that they saw
in him ah really it's going out and then
he died see that happens when I know
okay so we have another zone of comets
which predicted by a Dutch astronomer
dhyaan port and that's countless comets
a reservoir of comets they can come in
from any direction and it's very far
there's Proxima Centauri I tell you ours
are showing there's alkaline and just to
be clear obviously Tory's the name of
the entire system triple star system one
of which is Proxima Centauri yeah there
are serious serious remember going
another factor of 10 for each large tick
mark on the left every tick mark is a
factor of 10 in this so this is our
radio bubble how far the earliest radio
signals have reached space which would
include Hitler's 1936 Olympics some of
the first Emmis aerial signals that
aliens will receive now we're seeing the
entire Milky Way here there's one
hundred three hundred billion stars you
can count them as they go by the black
hole would be right there in the center
right in the center and so there's this
large and small Magellanic Cloud we
talked about them that's the distance
you would find them from us where again
factors of ten each tick mark that we go
there mm-hmm okay and now we're into the
realm of the galaxies and seeing the
near the nearest galaxies the Andromeda
galaxy that Neil mentioned and another
number of other galaxies that have have
names like whirlpool and sombrero and
other such things we like interesting
names we call them as we see them all
right we've looked as I think unlike the
chemists or the geologists we
yeah you know you know I'm right just
don't even go there the Crab Nebula it
look like a crab alright just we didn't
call it Orko Clay's feldspar all right
that's just this there don't here's the
Sloan Great Wall of galaxies this got me
and Mario your each in the Guinness Book
of World Records for the largest
structure in the air each dot here
represents a single galaxy we going out
now we don't show them one and one and
and finally we've reached to the most
distant distant galaxies and quasars the
quiz I've shown you will be right here
and rich you want to sell stuff and then
there's the stretching all the way 360
degrees around the sky is the Cosmic
Microwave Background sphere which I
showed you with that sphere there's a
map of it up there there it is that we
see all around us that's like coming to
us from left over from the Big Bang and
they're real and that's the universe
ladies and gentlemen thank you
J Richard rocked the third Michael
stroke
and that is about 5% of the book we have
two microphones here we would love to
take some got about 10 minutes for Q&A
and by the way we will be out out in the
hall of McClendon Northwest Coast
Indians to assign books by the way this
is the only occasion where all three of
us will be signing the book so this is
will be a unique thing just so you know
and what we got with people lining up
good about 10 minutes of Q&A
oh also if you must leave now because
you parked too far away you can pick up
a book that's pre-signed they don't have
to wait in line for the in the signing
line okay and we just say we encourage
children in particular to come and ask
question yes hello
well that's my microphone does not work
we'll come back to that let's come over
here yes okay do you plan to do a video
lecture series based on the book rich we
might in the future maybe yeah maybe not
not yet certainly don't think we thought
that the way the way to get it to the
book
thank you yes does this work yet yes can
you explain why there is really no
center of the universe even if you are
looking at it from where the edge of the
universe is so like the sensor from the
edge of the universe but on a standard
distance well that's a refute if you
imagine a big balloon a big balloon with
coins on it and the balloon is blowing
up the this is the picture of space
expanding the rubber of the balloon is
expanding space if you sit on a coin
it's the scotch tape to the balloon
you'll see all the other coins
Slean from you and it looks like you're
at the center okay just like we think
we're standing on top of the earth and
the poor people in Australia are hanging
upside down everyone thinks they're at
the centre but there is no particular
center all the coins are equivalent
and it's just a space that expanding but
you see the region around you and so
nobody's special in fact the very word
the very word Mediterranean means middle
of the earth and if translated and so
wherever people were they thought they
were in the middle that yes first of all
great lecture loved it in your equation
for the number of possible planets or
habitable planets or in the Goldilocks
zone there's another part that is made
earth sort of unique you touched on it
that we have of this satellites it's 1/6
the size of the planet which had much to
do with making the earth habitable our
body double that venus doesn't have a
large satellite and it's got runaway
greenhouse and its atmosphere was never
stripped away by a large satellite so
i'm wondering what effect and this is
speculation but what effect would you
have to be looking for this almost
double planet system within the within
the Goldilocks zone in order to find a
airing for life it's a great question
there's a lot of research on how
important was the moon in the formation
of not life itself you probably don't
need it for just simple life it's
whether you can have the stability
necessary to develop the complexities
that the bio diversity has given us that
we see I think but my my opinion there
is that it's it's a little overstated
how important the moon is yes it
stabilizes our our orbital ibeacon
stabilizes our axial tilt yes but just
think about how diverse life already is
on earth live life thriving in the
Arctic and in the tropics and in the so
so what if something Wiggles it up a
little more
alright for we know that could have
added even more biodiversity to the
system stresses to the environment will
render some animals extinct and others
then thrive so I'm not worried that now
we have to look for a habitable planet
that has a big moon stabilizing its
orbit that's my personal view
yeah I agree with that okay one tends to
get very specific about the Earth's
situation and say oh it must be followed
exactly that and some parts of it do
make sense you need to get the
temperature right to get liquid waters
as Neil described and there's a variety
of ways to do that but the moon is is a
bit more detailed than saying it's an
absolute requirement for life for some
people to save them the tithe which the
moon helps but the Sun gives you time to
but I mean that that might be helpful
getting an simians out of the ocean onto
the land such random in the title but it
doesn't seem it doesn't seem absolutely
necessary yeah okay right here sir yes
Lola why is our moon so big compared to
other moons what are some theories fine
yeah so our moon has a fascinating
backstory which was didn't come didn't
take shape until after the Apollo era
were they brought back samples on
purpose from the surface of the Moon and
we noticed that the moon is made mostly
of the same stuff of Earth's crust not
only that the moon is missing for an
object that size it should have sort of
the birth mixture of the stuff in the
solar system would include a certain
amount of carbon and oxygen and nitrogen
and but also some iron as Michael had
described is should be there in the moon
and we have a huge iron core in our own
planet the moon has hardly any iron so
why is all the iron in our core because
when we form iron is heavier than
silicon so iron goes to the core other
things rise to the top and it solidifies
the moon if it has no iron anywhere and
doesn't have an iron core what happened
and that led us thinking us people
thinking that maybe the moon was formed
later after Earth had already
differentiated in its materials and it
had led to the hypothesis that a
mars-sized object sideswiped earth
scooping up our surface material
reforming into then what became the moon
it's not far-fetched because in that
early part of the solar system there's
periods of very heavy bombardment where
planets are still accreting left
material from the formation of the solar
system and if it's small you just absorb
it but if it's big stuff happens now by
the way the moon just to be clear the
moon is a little heavier than 1/100 the
mass of the earth
okay so the earth is basically nearly
100 times more so it's actually not that
much material to give up yourself to
make a moon if I say give me 1/100 of
you you know
you're not going to miss it I promise
okay we have more than 100 hundreds of
ourselves on our butts and our bellies
alright walking around right now so so
yeah so that's a whole separate
storyline how we get this moon and that
would be different from how all the
other planets got their moons that's all
that's how we get a big one and they
don't yes right here hi a big fan of
star talk so think oh thank you for
doing that thank you a labor of love for
us all on the team yes if I could be a
bit of a fanboy for a second and that's
a personal question
you're very well known for being on top
of both science and pop culture and I'm
curious how someone like you have
manages to do both of that how where do
you get your news and how do you do that
it's cloning yeah so that's a great
question and it's nearly impossible and
I miss a lot but what I do is I mean I
cheat what I do is I look to see what is
the number one TV show and they said let
me catch a few episodes of that I look
at what is the number of the hottest
team right now so Cubs are in the World
Series
let me check up on that all right who's
in the who's in the Super Bowl
let me check up on that and so I al ik
ate my energy so the things that garner
the the deepest and most intense public
attention then that gives me fluency in
these places that people care about then
I take the laws of physics of the
universe and find ways that they can
plug in to all the things people already
care about so you come to the party with
this pop-culture scaffold and then I
clad it with the cosmos and then you
walk away not having to learn the
science as a
separate exercise because it just plugs
in to something you that that you
already know and love and an example of
this was I was channel surfing well
there were two examples of this let me
just give the most recent one I'm
channel surfing I got 15 minutes till a
movie I want to watch and I hit a
football game that just ends in a tie so
they go into a 15 minute overtime okay
15 minute overtime so I said I can fit
that in let me just watch this why not
all right so there's a new rule we have
to change hands a couple of times before
okay and then it's sudden death so we go
to sudden death and so the guy then they
get close enough like 50 yards away for
the kicker to kick the field goal for
the win so there he kicks it and then
the ball goes and it's tumbling and it's
sort of drifting to the left and it hits
the left up right and then bounces in
for the win and I said wait a minute
this is a round ball hitting a roundup
right over that distance I checked the
orientation of the stadium I did you
know carry the 2s and and I said oh I
said I tweeted this winning field goal
by the Cincinnati Bengals or was it
against the synced name it forgot which
was enabled by a third of an inch drift
in the trajectory of the ball enable
empowered by the rotation of the earth
the Coriolis force double bond if you're
playing on the equator - so so I didn't
have to explain what a fuel goal is what
football is where the bangles are that's
your scalp that's your scaffold and I
just gave you the Coriolis force and
football and people like it lost their
minds on this it was like all over
Cincinnati news I got phone calls from
ESPN and that was a very simple exercise
by the way any one of my colleagues I
don't carry special knowledge into these
exercises I just happen to do it well
they're actually busy in the lab all
right so that's that's how it happens
thank you thanks for that yes I'm with
proposed ideas such as using lasers shot
at a sail for me - the acceleration do
you see us getting to Alpha Centauri
system in next 100 years rich that's a
rich person well I got a repeat the
question so so you're talking about this
recent announcement where you have these
sort of nano craft that are propelled by
the pressure of laser light we can
accelerate to such high speed you get
there very quickly rich go well they got
a billionaire working on this it's
useful several several several people in
my department are working on this so
they're they're hoping and by the way
part of astrophysics at Princeton
University yeah they all that group
celebrated when they found this planet
around Proximus until I that's the
nearest star so this gives them a goal
to go to it's the easy to star to get to
so they're they're working on that okay
yeah yes right here hi hi so again try
not to come up to the microphone and
then cough yeah yeah that's just just so
you know next time okay so given that we
have a supermassive black hole at the
center of the Milky Way is the Milky Way
actually collapsing in on itself so
maybe I should take that one so imagine
for at the thought experiment the Sun
turns into a black hole tomorrow this
would be this would be bad news for many
reasons of course they are our source of
heat and life would disappear
but the orbit of the earth around around
the Sun would continue exactly as it is
one often has this mental image of a
black hole as a cosmic vacuum cleaner
and that's not really true in the sense
that if you're an orbit around a black
hole if you're far enough away it's just
as stable as an orbit around an ordinary
star a star with the same mass start
with the same mass I should have
qualified that so I showed a movie in
which we saw the orbits of stars around
that central black hole and they will
keep on going for for literally billions
of years nothing nothing will change
that
it's only when you get very very close
to the black hole that it can swallow
things and those orbits are perfectly
stable and will stay on for any
astronomical timescale billions of years
if we go even longer than more
interesting things happen and that
gravitational radiation that I was
talking about can eventually take over
but but no our Milky Way is quite safe
on billions of year timescales to the
Tibetan what's the mass of that black
hole in our galaxy four times the four
million times the mass of the Sun and
what's the match the black hole in
Andromeda um I think that I was about
more right say 10 billion million or so
I should know that number off the top so
black holes not as big as their black
hole yeah that's right so do a little
only old we have black hole MV : of
course yeah okay quasar I showed you was
a billion yeah a business so one of the
triumphs of the Hubble telescope is to
help us recognize that practically every
galaxy that we can measure has a black
supermassive black hole in its core so
that is another ingredient in the
modeling of people are trying to know
how to make galaxies in the first place
on a computer by the way this thing that
whether are black holes big vacuums
there's an old joke they said there's no
such thing as gravity earth just sucks
right okay yes right here so the cosmic
maximum where I told you 10 10 that is
so cool
and this is a school night okay good
just say you were here if just say you
were here I already did that okay go
ahead look good
wait so the cosmic microwave by
background verse is basically a bunch of
microwaves that you come from inside a
microwave so it'll cook you from the
inside out
thank you make a cosmic microwave oven
we're in a cosmic microwave oven but
it's a very low temperature it sits
about we're seeing this as a temperature
of about 2.7 degrees above absolute zero
so we're getting these microwaves all
the time they're left over from the Big
Bang they used to be very much shorter
wavelength but the universe is expanded
so the microwave background radiation is
very cool and it doesn't if I could burn
you up for a good thing thanks for that
encouraging information so I try to try
this experiment when you go home I
presume you're in your household there's
a microwave oven well that's why I join
it so find something you want to cook
but set the microwave power to its
lowest level it takes about nine hours
to cook the book so the intensity the
microwaves matters in this conversation
and yes the cousin microwave is not
going to cook you from the inside out we
promise okay I remember watching cosmos
and say you hearing I'm hearing you what
sing as some universe expands it gets
cooler and cooler yes you won't hear
that again as the universe expands it
gets cooler
but the cosmos voice okay thanks for
watching it by the way yeah yeah now
it's just time for a couple more
questions we'll call it a night yeah I
was just wondering if it would be
theoretically possible to harness the
Hawking radiation of a black hole as an
energy source it's a very very faint
it's instead of being microwaves it's
kilometres long it's so faint you it's
really beyond our ability to detect it I
don't think anybody doubts that it's
there there's a lot of reasons for
believing it's theoretically if we could
have detected it by now
Hawking would have already gotten his
Nobel Prize but it's predicted I think
no one doubts that it's there it's just
very long wavelength radio waves yes
right here hi um this might be a bit
complicated I'm wondering I we coming up
with a theoretical standpoint can black
holes actually be in the universe
because in things like the Oppenheimer
Snyder metric um there are there's an
event horizon that takes an infinite
amount of time to form the apparent
horizon either which was asymptotically
reached that point so could we ever have
a black hole with an event horizon what
you're saying is that black health ever
form enough to so we can see the black
hole as a black ball rather that's what
you mean right
yeah given time dilation prevents it
from ever happening from how we see it
rich well it forms an event horizon then
if you were watching something falling
in it would it would seemingly take a
long long time like an infinite amount
of time for it to fall in you see them
falling in and they were descending you
signals saying hi things are
you know and you're actually there
saying things are going badly but they
go in and you never see the going badly
part when they're ripped apart by the
tidal forces inside the black hole
because that like signals are never
getting back out to you but we can see
this this process of the event arising
forming and then the reverberation that
occurs that was seen in LIGO so we've
actually seen the two event arises of
the black hole merged into making the
one event horizon and we have the
gravity waves to show it so you get the
infinite it's happening at that edge so
so if you can see things that as time
dilated as in their limits right because
of the existence of the event horizon
itself yeah but it takes you if if you
want a spaceship inside it take you a
finite amount of time to cross that
event horizon go inside if that was you
if that were yeah yeah there's an entire
chapter on the sub there's a chapter on
black hole yeah I told you this whole
talk was only 5% of the book so let's go
really fast as I want to get to Resco
will go into sound bite mode for answers
go it's probably a bit complicated okay
there we go someone else right okay all
right go we'll try go the universe is
expanding ever accelerating its
expansion that means that presumably at
some point it's going to form enough
vacuum space in between everything for
the vacuum to become charged again for
another would it be possible for the
vacuum to be charged enough to create
another universe within our universe and
kind of that could you article it is a
good one yeah well we have a very low
vacuum energy today it's not that it's
becoming electrically charged it's just
that as the vacuum expands it gets more
and more space there's the possibility
that there's a lower energy vacuum state
available and and therefore you'll make
some time in the far future and people
talk about 10 to the 138 years or longer
ten to the ten
34 years in some case and some models of
that bubbles of lower vacuum energy
state may may occur and then it's like
sort of eternally fizzing champagne with
bubble newer bubble universes farming in
the ever-expanding vacuum which can
expand so fast the space rips uh well
there's that would be bad
well there's a model called the big rip
model where where the vacuum energy is
going up with time it doesn't look like
this is occurring it looks like it's
staying constant but in that case after
a finite time it would all the bodies
like Neil and the earth and everything
be ripped apart and then there being a
singularity and everything would be
ripped apart but it doesn't look like
that's what we're seeing we look like
the vacuum energy staying constant which
means it's just going to keep doubling
and doubling and doubling in size at the
same energy density and eventually new
bubbles may form in the far far future
so you say we probably won't get ripped
apart doesn't look like okay just gotta
go real quick go okay this is for this
questions for a group of students right
eight years old can you explain how the
Dynamo effect for them causes the
magnetosphere
boy that's a sophisticated question for
a girl that it's in layman's terms we're
we're not out of science we're going to
need a valid age so this is a statement
about how the magnetic field of the
earth was formed and it has to do with
and I and I don't have a detailed answer
to this in fact it's not well known but
the interior the earth is roiling in a
variety of ways the very core and mantle
the earth and there and there are
charged currents that actually set up
that magnetic field and the Dynamo
effect refers to the process by which
that magnetic fields can build itself up
again it's not not fully understood
either in the case of the the earth or
for that matter in the Sun but it helps
that you have molten iron the iron that
can actually move as a core today earth
completely cools down we expect the
magnetic field to go away entirely but
as is the case with other rocky planets
been around
balloon for example the moon doesn't
have iron so yeah yeah magnetic field it
has we got no more yeah right here go
yes
how old are you I'm twelve twelve cool
give it to me
alright does the universe expand from
the center or from the side and how does
this happen it's just all expanding the
space between all the galaxies is
expanding again it's like imagine the
surface of a balloon if you were a
two-dimensional creature an ant walking
around on the service of balloon you
only knew about those two dimensions the
universe is just getting bigger so as
the balloon blows up the the space is
expanding between the galaxies and it's
just getting bigger there's no galaxy
that's the center more than any other
galaxy I would also say that since the
balloon is expanding in this analogy
there is a center of the balloon it's
down in the middle but that's where
everything was at the beginning of the
universe
so one think of the center of the
universe think of the Big Bang itself
after that there is no center not in any
accessible place for any of the galaxies
that exist okay yes at what speed does
the universe expand at well the you know
that the further what counts here's
relative speed if we're sitting here we
think we're sitting still we look at a
distant galaxy the more distant the
galaxy the faster it's moving that is
the nature of the extension we talk
about this in the book the nearby gap
nearby galaxies are moving it may be
only a thousand kilometers every second
the more distant objects are moving
close to the speed of light or indeed in
some sense exceeding the speed of light
and we talked about that in some detail
in the book it's moving fast yeah yeah I
got time for like we'll take four fast
questions go yes
what made it most motivated you to
become at you all to become master
physicist who let's say that once the
last step aside stay here yeah right
here go um how many black holes are in
this galaxy ah that's a good question
there's only one really big one in the
very center people argue a lot about how
many smaller black holes black holes
which may be only a few times the mass
of the
Sun may exist we know of about I would
say dozen or dozen but that but they're
hard to see right we talked about we can
infer the presence of a handful of them
I don't know off the top of my head with
the current estimates for the number in
the Milky Way there the number must be
in the many tens of thousands but I
don't happen to know something to keep
in mind is avoid them yeah okay
thank you yes this is just a theory that
I kind of made up from what I learned
here uh what's in your basement your
parents know what you're doing they're
just wondering this is how we get the
nemesis to superheroes we'll try to be
really nice to you all right so what is
it so as you guys said I think it
disappointed look on your face change so
as you guys said before stars keep on
compressing elements into other ones and
making them heavier and iron is the last
ditch attempt into keeping the star like
you know alive that's right so then
eventually one of the universe's tending
to sputter wouldn't like all the
hydrogen helium and their Forge and
because all there is is iron and black
holes floating around that's a rush yeah
the universe will end in exactly the way
you described it said I go back to
watching all the gas clouds that give us
the birth ingredients of stars will run
out of their ingredients they'll make
stars the Stars will run out of fuel
they will burn out no new stars will be
made and as you looked up at the night
sky the stars will disappear one by one
never to be replaced again and we will
have an entire universe of darkness
haven't I say yeah okay no right here so
I've heard and then naturally without
over years
on nine you're nine okay this is like
the last two questions here I get good
where went over time but we get the kids
in okay go thank you enjoy way past
their bedtime I know because it's past
my bedtime
go hug the Andromeda galaxy and the
Milky Way galaxy are going to collide
with each other well our species B um
interfere with and how it huh well the
first thing so though he's nine years
old he's worried about something's going
to happen in seven billion years deeply
worried about it go Mike so our species
you asked about our species our species
has been around for maybe a million
years three seven million years 4,000
for us all that savings yeah in fact
your cro-magnon Orlan yeah so a species
change on timescales of a million years
we're talking about billions of years
you can say it again Neil really in
thank you and so our species will not be
around in fact when the two galaxies
collide the space between the stars
which we heard about from rich it's so
large the Stars basically pass right
back past each other where our distant
descendants are really not going to be
worried very much by the collision of
the two gallons but it'll be an awesome
train wreck if you watch it because the
gravity distorts what were otherwise the
beautiful spiral patterns that are to
respective galaxies currently enjoy and
it'll be this mangled tangled mess and I
was wondering whether stars will go by
you could have like a fly by looting
where your gravitational legions might
be compromised if a car stars won't
necessarily collide but if they come too
close we won't remember which star we're
supposed to be or we get which galaxies
were butter or the planets that's right
yeah yeah yeah so so it'll be a
fascinating future and I blessed I did
the calculation it's about seven billion
years from now so watch so put that on
your smartphone and to look up huh yeah
well unless he said he won't live to see
it unless you invent something that
enables you to live to see it
yeah okay little Asian zone with the
last question yeah okay second last
question about this er go um since you
can look back in space to you look far
enough into space to see back in time
think there'd be a way to see earth back
in time a little bit in that there's if
you have a black hole if you have a
black hole light from the earth can go
around the black hole and come back and
we could see it again so faint you know
the cancer you're just picking up one
photon is this really small so it's
possible in principle but not really in
practice but you you see the earth is it
used to be that many light years that
many years ago depending on how far away
the black hole was what's what's a
practical answer to that question would
be imagining other aliens at a certain
distance from earth where light from
early Earth is only now just reaching
them so think of a galaxy that might be
65 million light years away so they are
seeing light from Earth that earth sent
out 65 million years ago and what was
happening 65 million years ago dinosaurs
were rendered extinct by one of our
objects an asteroid so if you are 65
million light years away you will be
seeing t-rex croak in real time and that
would be really cool I would think okay
can you take one more question here
before we go to that young lady okay
okay let me say it better be an awesome
question everyone is watching okay so
your so you briefly mentioned
gravitational waves earlier and how like
the how like two black holes merge to
create a single black hole display like
dilation of like a tiny fraction of
atomic nucleus like what kind of
dilation would you get if you like if I
to supermassive black holes ah they said
oh the Europeans are in the process of
developing a
satellite called Lisa that will instead
of measuring four kilometers will be
four million kilometers across and they
are trying to look for the mergers of
pairs of supermassive black holes which
might happen if two galaxies collide but
the typical distance that you might
expect to see that is even larger and
therefore the effect that we measure is
going to be comparable small so stay
tuned that is something that we may have
an answer to in our lifetimes but we're
not there yet
and let me hold you are you're 12 and
you asked us how did we each find our
calling yes is it basically rich I got
interested in astronomy when I was eight
years old I found a book in the
bookstore with a celestial globe a bunny
is made of paper and it's fun and
there's they used to be sold in these
places called bookstores okay go and and
and I got interested in astronomy when I
was eight and I joined a young
astronomers Club and so I've been
interested in astronomy ever since when
I was in high school I was reading a lot
about astronomy and thought it was
really cool I loved looking at the night
sky I remember telling my dad I want to
be an astronomer and he said you can't
get a job doing that I oh he was happy
to see that I that I eventually proved
him wrong and I mean we have the entire
universe to look at it but it keeps us
very busy so I am like hugely visible
like in places like the internet and
they and so people hear my story and
they think it's it's either special or
unusual because they're not hearing any
of my colleagues also tell their story
about how they became astrophysicist but
in fact my story is common common as the
breeze among us rich got got interested
at age eight I got interested at age
nine when my parents brought me to my
local planetarium the Hayden Planetarium
it was the Stars you know they dimmed
the lights the stars came out I thought
it was a hoax that's too many stars I've
seen them from the Bronx
there's 12 of them so this is a
deception it's an it's an entertaining
deception but don't you're not fooling
me
and I would ultimately learn that in
fact it was the sky as is actually
represented in the actual universe but
and by age 11 I knew enough by reading
books from the library books my parents
bought me for my birthday
this is that by age 11 I had an answer
to that annoying question that adults
always ask kids what do you want to be
when you grow up and up at age 11
onwards I said I want to be an
astrophysicist that pretty much shut
them up because they you know so you
know if you say I want to be a doctor Oh
uncle uncle Al Gore or Aunt Betty as a
doctor you say astrophysicist that was
it they just walked away at that point
and it was so uh to this day I'm a
little bit scarred for having not known
a night-sky until I saw one in the
Hayden Planetarium
because from those mountaintops in Chile
and to this day when I go to commune
with the cosmos in these singularly
majestic sites and I look up at the
night sky I say to myself it reminds me
of the Hayden planned gentlemen thank
you all for coming thank you rich got
Michael Krause
we'll see you at the year in review in
January
have a good night